you
um
because uh
at this point in time we'll open up the
work uh session on
hb680 uh there's a continued work
session from the previous
meeting we met on monday ago and
we will try to continue where we were on
the bill in going through the initial
presentation of that bill that we were
looking at
uh we had dropped off at page
what is it
14 are there abouts
well i think we think we actually
finished up through the accountability
section i mean yeah we were we did get
we did get through
um
were we on page
top of page 16 or
our
yeah i think we did get through uh the
whole bill but i don't think we spent a
lot of time on sections 15 and 16 on on
page 14.
and you know and i think it's it's worth
spending a few minutes talking about
that maybe while we're while we're
waiting
for the department
yeah so mike i'm wondering if you can
explain to me
what happens if
these turnaround plans
get
developed
and then
the goals are not met so so there's
there's
there's nothing in the accountability
sections margarine thanks
um that are designed to be
you know punitive or pejorative to um to
any school district
and and um
and
it's important i think that that
what um what we do as a state and and
and conducted obviously through the
department of ed
that they're able to collect information
so that we can we can you know maybe
even down the road more accurately
measure student performance
and right now the data that we have are
basically the how students perform on
the statewide assessment tests
and attendance and graduation rates
and
and you know
graduation rates are certainly important
uh you know in terms of how how school
districts are
performing so our attendance rates too
and and you know it's it's you know i
think we're fortunate that a lot of us
on this committee have been members of
school boards before
and um and certainly i recall our
superintendent saying all the time that
um that
time is the currency of education
and uh and so the amount of time spent
in school um you know uh you know with
uh with you know teachers providing
instruction um
uh and with your classmates is uh is is
really important so so
so the the factors that are currently
being used in in 1680 as far as
measuring student performance basically
the tests attendance and uh and
graduation rates
um
the
the top part of
of uh and i want to try to find the
page that we're on
for that
would it be
page 11 and 12
yes yeah so that top part
um starting on page i think
nine and going into ten really talks
about um you know data that the uh that
the department uh uh could be collecting
uh to um you know to help um determine
how uh how students are doing in in
districts across the state and then uh
the part that you're talking about
really begins i think in section 11 at
the bottom of page 10
where we're talking about um
uh
the um
schools the basically the bottom twenty
percent of school districts would be um
uh would be
you know considered to be
underperforming
and and again this isn't this isn't
trying to be punitive it's really trying
to trying to find ways where we can
support
administrations
and you know we've heard a lot about in
the committee too about things like best
practice folders and stuff like that but
support the administration in being able
to um to
help
you know improve students whether it's
performance on tests or or graduation
rates and attendance rates
and
yeah and i i understand all that
my experience
has been that
in the school where i taught
which was always called underperforming
was that we were always trying to
improve and
we focused all the time on
making those indicators go up and we
worked really hard at that so that other
things kind of got left behind yeah and
and maybe my experience is
unusual but
i just
worry about it i worry about calling
schools underperforming and
and and making them have an improvement
plan that
may or may not
really be implemented well or may have a
change in
leadership i know we lost
superintendents for a while we were
saying we had a superintendent of the
week because we hadn't didn't have a
superintendent for longer than a year at
a time
all those things come in um
but aren't
necessarily
um
credited and so the blame comes down to
the classroom teacher and i just feel
like
then
that's the other ones that are striving
so hard to meet all their kids needs and
i know i get emotional because i just
feel like there's a
and i know maybe this is not the
function of this committee but
somehow or other we have to make sure
that the people who are working in those
underperforming schools where the kids
are not
growing the way they're supposed to grow
that we understand that that's not for
lack of effort on behalf of the people
who are working with those children
and that there's other things that can
influence how well a child performs
that's out of the control of uh
of the local school
yeah i think there are two categories
of quote unquote underperforming schools
mandated in federal law in the essa
program
so it's it's it's part of that's coming
down i think it dates back to no child
left behind sure um so you know that's
that's a federal requirement so there's
not much we can do about it we have to
comply
with that provision and i think that
there's um
uh
percentages in terms of was it percent
and ten percent something like that uh
to define whether a
school is in
category one or two which i think
i think they're still called tsi and csi
so so i i think with this bill and i
hear what you're saying marjorie and and
glenn that you know what we're
you know there there certainly are
requirements
at through um through through sf
um and no child and formerly no child
left behind but the the most important
thing about house bill 1680 is that it's
designed
right at the top
to establish
a a foundation opportunity budget
so that a school district can educate
all of its students to a statewide
outcome which is a really strong outcome
in in new hampshire
right now that's not how school
districts are
are financed and funded in in new
hampshire so so the access to resources
that the hillsborough deering district
have are very different than the access
to resources that other districts across
the state have like let's just pick
lincoln
um you know for instance
and um and and frankly they're they're
they're different than than the access
to resources that um that we might have
in hopkinton i mean which also has high
property tax rates um
so
so by by by starting with a a foundation
opportunity budget plan
designed so that so that the
hillsborough deering district can
educate their kids to a statewide
average outcome the hopkinton kids can
the homeland district can educate it
kids its kids to a statewide average
outcome
uh will uh will
go i think a lot further
for um uh
you know in making sure that under
districts are so being supported by the
state and i'm not saying being supported
by by well you know you know you should
get rid of all your teachers or you
should you know
do this and do that administratively but
but getting the financial support they
need to be able to meet to be able to
have you know have a realistic budget
and um and so that's what the whole
first part of the bill is about when
we're when we're getting to this part
marjorie um
and this is important to talk about the
accountability doesn't even come in
until two years after the first part of
the bill
comes in and i'm not saying that our
current
accountability standard is necessarily
the right way to be measuring uh schools
but but we understand that it's going to
take time and it's probably going to
take more than two years time
um for um you know for for uh student
outcomes to uh to begin to move in the
direction that the opportu that the
foundation
opportunity plan um predicts they will
uh i i'd like to just kick in here
because we're talking about the policy
and accountability portions of this and
and i think it's important that we also
be looking at 193e
uh 3
where we have correct
corrective
and technical assistance provided to
districts which aren't achieving what
they need to with many of these
subgroups within
uh the
targeted monies and and when i say
targeted i say it very
with quotes around because it's really
not targeted money as we have right now
and
and i i
look at if you're in corrective and
technical assistance in the third year
it gives the commissioner education
we're under current law right now
to
assess the schools how they're spending
their funds are the funds being directed
towards the purpose of those funds
but that's only in the third year
that that is it says to require the
school to provide an accounting of how
funds are being used to provide the
opportunity for an adequate uh education
assess how the school is expanding its
educational funds and may order the
adequacy funds be redirected to address
those areas that are
failing
and won't read anymore so that's in
current law right now i
i oftentimes ask the department how how
often do you get to this point
where we see that the
the the gap between some of the students
who are in these subgroups is getting
larger between those that are achieving
those or not
and that is a significant certain
concern i know of the commissioner and
of the department right now
so i anything which we do pass that has
this in here
like i'm looking on page 12
line 16-17 where you're talking for
about persistent disparities which are
reflective
it says establish statewide targets for
addressing persistent uh disparities
and you develop this plan
i
anything that we do
i think we ought to really have some
some language inserted that really gives
the
commissioner the opportunity the ie the
department to target those monies where
these gaps are getting larger
and i'd i'd look at 193e
and and do the comparison to make sure
because there was some good stuff
whether it be was being
done or not i can't say
so
okay
i'm trying to put this in
i'm not arguing with people and i'm not
finding fault but
what if the way to close these gaps
is to get rid of the lead pipes
leading into the homes in the town
because this kids
have a high level of lead
in their water
or what if the way to get rid of these
gaps is to provide
um
preschool
universal preschool
to all the students in the district so
that kids entering kindergarten
are all entering
at about the same starting line
what if those are the things that are
needed is it
is that
okay so those are the kinds so those
kinds of things
could potentially
enter into
um the money that the district receives
to
what you're talking about representative
porter is exactly what i've always
screamed about
what is the aspiration of the community
what is the shape of the family what is
this you know all those issues which are
ones where you can throw a lot of money
at something and it's not necessarily
going to touch and achieve what you're
trying to do there are a lot of issues
that money can resolve but there's some
that it can't you know the it's it's
it's almost like culture
so i i i concur with you
uh however there
there are situations that we all know of
that if the
the instruction may be matched more the
learning style of the student and we get
those two things on the same level so
instruction can be teaching one way and
the child learns a totally different way
those are all
in every school we've had in services
and time for teachers to understand that
and
we want to be looking at that component
as well as we want to be looking at the
the
those other issues that you're speaking
to representative porter there's a whole
lot comes together in trying to see how
to close these gaps
so
can i can i jump in here for a comment
um
accountability is good
i mean accountability in and of itself
is a good thing because it allows us to
sort of trace the dime in the dollar and
look at
whether or not the outcomes that we want
are the outcomes that we're getting what
i think this bill does in a way that uh
is frankly exciting to me is when when
you talk
about the school improvement plans and
the persistent disparities
it actually spells out what the process
is
should those disparities be uncovered
i'm looking on page 12 section roman 2
line 21.
that section starts with uh
districts establishing targets for
addressing persistent disparities
and
it tells you what has to happen not what
we want to happen but what has to happen
that each district shall develop an
evidence-based three-year plan that each
district shall be developed by the
superintendent in consultation with the
school board and shall consider input
shall consider input and recommendations
from parents other relative
community stakeholders
special education english learner parent
advisory council school improvement
councils i mean i think that
utilizing the brain trust to do the
finances is part one
but coming up with a solution that we
can at least all get on board with on
what we're going to do when we uncover
what we don't want to uncover is part
two
and i i don't want that to get lost
because of the price tag
not that we've got an unlimited amount
of funds obviously we don't and that's
why we're all sitting here but uh
but i do think that there is
accountability in this bill that is very
clearly spelled out
and uh
i approve of that accountability
thank you representative that was very
helpful you're right i have not
spent enough time cruising all the
different little parts that are in here
but yes so something that's also part of
that accountability is that is is and
and we we don't have that in in our
current this in our current statute
is um is the connection
of of student outcomes through
accountability because it's met you can
measure these things
performance on statewide tests
ascendance graduate rate graduation
rates plus down the road additional
metrics can be can be considered but but
how that feedbacks feeds back into
the the funding formula
as it's reevaluated at least every 10
years at least no less frequently than
every 10 years
and um and and because of the the
you know the method the statistic
basically a statistical method of
analyzing what what um school districts
how they're spending their money what
they're spending money on and what their
student outcomes are
that can be
that that's a very tight feedback loop
with with accountability
and and so now really for the first time
accountability gets some gets put right
into the the system of how you go about
costing
a foundation opportunity budget that
closes these opportunity gaps for uh for
students in the uh in the state
representative cordelli i did think of
you repeatedly as i was reading this
bill
yes
and quite surprising one might say but
the references to parent involvement in
this in this bill which i know is
something that is near and dear to you
um
i i i mean i i
i applaud you representative luno for
the number of times in the variety of
ways that you were able to
sort of put a highlighter over the need
to get community involvement in
total ownership of the school plan in
order to
really do what
representative ladd and representative
porter are talking about and that is
meet the specific needs of a community
not just a sort of the
generic needs right right and not just
at budget time not just when you're
voting at the school district meeting
but um but when considering how your how
students are performing and and what um
i mean this is more than just
aspirational this is
you know i think this is what what
voters have expected for a long time in
new hampshire and why
um why new hampshire has such good
student outcomes
well i think that the the flight path
you're talking about with the benchmarks
along the way towards achieving those
academic standards which are set by the
state
now how we do it
is set by the local
so what we've got to do is ensure that
there is our specific benchmarks as you
allude to represent mullen along the way
that give us the metric give us the
information that's needed to say
we're on course or we're not on course
and no matter how you slice and dice
this
there's going to have to be strong
supervision there's going to have to be
strong alignment between what is being
taught and those academic standards that
we have set
we're measuring our achievement based
upon standards which are in a given
instrument
if that instrument's not measuring what
our academic styles are properly we've
got to get on top of that too and that's
where the course the repeal to repeal
the in oversight committee is very
important
but i believe that
if all this has to be connected
and and they're going to be those hard
times in a school where you see that the
school may be teaching something which
is not part of not going towards that
academic standard that's you may have
good teachers but teachers that are not
on the same page as that academic
standard is that's where that
supervision is critical
and supervision can come in from the we
refer to that as the thinning of the
garden in bedford representative ladd
and it has i can guarantee you that it
has not always been a popular approach
because it means that some people's
favorite units of study
you know i i'm aware of the fact that we
had a unit of study on corn in bedford
new hampshire in the elementary schools
and it was fascinating and it was fun
and
it had to go
because
the outcomes from you know the outcomes
that were being measured and the
benchmarks that were being uh attempted
in the unit
were a mismatch they're not matching and
that's that
i believe as the school principal for so
many years i had to watch out for that
um we had a number of field trips going
out sometimes the field trips were one
so wonderful socially and all that but
no relationship to
what we're doing and there's only x
number of days in the school year and if
you sacrifice 10 to do these wonderful
things
go and watch the red sox play baseball
yeah i can see that matches up with a pe
type
standard somewhere along the way so but
is that what we should be doing um
so right right and and and what you're
saying there rick about how
how um
how how spending gets tied to outcomes
to student performance
that's um that's something that's uh
that
that's sort of tied in with the
efficiency um
you know of of how districts spend money
and um
and and also it's it's uh it's tied in
with the information that um that air uh
analyzed when they were looking at how
districts across the state do spend
money and we talked a little bit about
this last week
districts that tend to have
have fewer resources tighter budgets
tend to spend money more efficiently
than um than than districts that don't
that that actually comes out in the in
the in the evidence statewide
and um and when looking at the data you
can actually sort of see what what sort
of um spending categories or or what
sort of spending doesn't manifest itself
in
student outcomes the way other um
you know
budgeted line items you know spending uh
does
and um and i think that's what um
what's really what what what sue
referenced in on page 12
section 13 line 23 evidence space 3 or
plan to meet its targets so you're
really having a targeted student outcome
and make sure that you're spending um
your budget is aligned with um with
achieving those outcomes
okay go ahead would that relate then
back to the
uh infamous doe 25 form and what's being
reported to the state um
making sure that it can take
making sure that it has that level of
detail to determine that absolutely
let's uh take advantage of we got uh doe
hats arrived at our doorstep
and welcome mark
um
so uh
oliver
thank you mr chair uh
i was just listening very much and
getting educated on the academic
perspective of this i wonder if maybe
there's an element that might be better
considered
in the health
and property value and those kinds of
issues if you were to give this
performance thing and there were at
least an implicit or maybe explicit
connection between the lead pipes that
representative porter was talking about
and the health and mental acuity of
students that it might be shifted at
least into higher community interest and
maybe more of an imperative and
therefore you could achieve not just the
school system not having lead pipes but
making the town
agree that nobody should have lead pipes
and that way you can begin to achieve
that objective
but with more direct community
involvement yes the person selling their
house is going to howl
of course they don't want to have any
more restrictions but the fact of the
matter if you can't sell your house
until you've changed the pipes then
you've changed one unit in town no
matter what the aquifer might be or
where the source of the alien might
eventually be traced to you could get
the appropriate state officials in to
determine that and then move from that
point just a thought
if you um representative ford if you
look at page 11 roman 4 starting on line
i think you're going to find that it
addresses a lot of exactly what you're
saying it talks about
the social services and health needs of
students
child welfare expanding law enforcement
as necessary
workforce development there's a whole
section in there that i think is is
exactly bull's-eyed in on what you're
talking about
thank you i i understood that part but
what i was really responding to is i
heard you all talking and you were sort
of taking the blame on the school system
and then trying to deal with it and i'm
saying it's not all us folks
other people need to take part of the
blame too
i think we got to be very careful before
we
do a lot of subjective type stuff here
um there are districts right beside each
other in the direct opposite polar
polarized from each other you know and
with a lot of the same condition
uh so there are a lot of factors there
are multiple factors which come into
what is achievement what is growth
so um
but i think that what you got to do is
incorporate all those factors as
conditions and they may weigh
differently with different districts
so there is that uniqueness where local
control and and everything's different
every valley in this state has a
different way of doing something it's
kind of unfortunate in one way but
another way it's kind of wonderful that
it's still new hampshire
so let's go on and get involved here
with the next part mark and and and dave
and let's let's go jump beyond the the
page which we've been on with 12 and and
13 and start talking on the top of you
know
the
page 14 when you start talking things
like the statewide education property
tax and getting on to specifics
one of the things i'm curious to know
about and and i'll explain it is that
how we come up with what is the average
cost or the cost you're saying shows
that we're at the performance level we
have to be what is that dollar figure
how did we get that dollar figure
from the doe 25
and and so that whole conversation we
have to have somewhere along the way
here
so let's start with page 14 or so and
move onwards i think it was about that
where we stopped somewhere where we we
had some information on statewide
education property tax that was provided
earlier um
we can start there or we could even leap
and go on on some of the other pages
which yeah so let me um
let me take an after fact um could we
invite um representative ames sure to uh
to take us through the um um the uh the
revenue and um
and uh and the and the swept um
before before we take tackle that rick
you asked a really big question about
how do you determine what the um what
the district budgets are to to
to you know to achieve
uh a certain outcome performance level
in a in a school district and um and
that is done through uh through
statistical analysis
and uh and it was done through um
using uh
really using 10 years worth of
doe you know data collected by every
district and connecting it with the with
the average student outcomes in each of
these districts
so what i'd what i would suggest we we
may want to do and uh whether we do it
next week or do it at some point down
the road is um is maybe hear from the
people that that did that analysis and
they can they can really get into um to
exactly how that's done but it's
basically looking at formulas that that
that contain
student characteristics like like you
know the the number of english language
learners the number of students on ieps
the number of students free and reduced
prices there's a whole discussion there
and
i'm with you on that i think that would
be uh we need to have that discussion
yeah uh let's take advantage of the
folks we have right now with dick and
mark right and and and get this
explanation here let's get it down to
about 15 000 foot sounds good all right
so um
so we're i think rick you've moved us uh
just beyond adequacy i mean beyond the
accountability section to the top of of
page 14
where we talk about the
statewide education property tax i think
we touched on it a little bit
uh last week
with representative ames and attorney
artinger and um and maybe we can sort of
start where uh where we left off uh
there and and then go through um
the um
go through how um
the the effect on um on
charter schools and um and and basically
per pupil funding and then going into
the
property tax
yes the back part yeah good
welcome dick
thank you i actually didn't expect to be
sitting up here because
that's not a problem but i feel like
another chair that's more comfortable
i've got several in the back that's not
it i
i
i'm happy to go ahead with the property
tax statewide property tax issue i
thought we had covered a good part of
that last time
um i had a handout that i
i gave to you all i dropped my papers
back there so it was hard to find things
but uh it was a one-pager and then
as well
that the sections that relate to
reform of the statewide education
property tax reform
are also in another bill
that bill has been processed by the
house ways and means committee
was re it was uh reported out it was
retained studied
reported out with a
recommendation for interim study and the
house acted on that
putting it into interim study with ways
and means
in january
so that's where
where that
and those provisions sit on the ways of
means study i would on the side on the
net ways on the inside
i would say that the uh
committee as a whole
you know it was really unanimous felt
that this was an important
provision that
would bring a greater degree of
relief
to property taxpayers
than
has been there before and
that relief is enabled by the reform of
the statewide property tax
basically bringing into play
resources sufficient to provide
substantial relief to
property taxpayers from
not just the statewide education
property tax
which is a low rate
but also from the school tax
itself the local school tax so both
of those rates as applied to a
particular homeowner's property produce
a cost to the
taxpayer
and that cost is what
is
that cost will be relieved in some
fashion depending on the homeowner's
circumstances
through this bill so that's that's
that's a 30 000 foot level
description of this we can go into
details but i'm not sure that you should
uh spend much time on those details up
to you of course
but uh
basically it's raising uh income levels
for eligibility from where they are in
the
law right now
uh raising the amounts that can be
paid out for relief to a homeowner up to
a maximum of a thousand dollars
because it also has in it a cap on
on what can be spent under this program
of 25 million dollars so
there's definitely an attempt to stay
within bounds but also to provide
substantial relief
that's basically it
i didn't go over section by section when
i said that
i didn't before when we spoke
briefly about this in the previous
meeting of this subcommittee but
we can certainly do that if you want to
do that
what are how are you get how are you
arriving at this figure of the homestead
value of 150 000. why that figure it was
a raise from the existing level i i
don't have in my head what the existing
level is but it's much lower
and uh
it was sort of taking
look at looking around and how did how
did the previous level relate to prices
at that time
and how does this level relate to prices
at this time i don't recall exactly to
tell you the truth there's a substantial
increase above the well
maybe explain to me who sets that uh
that rate uh is it uh
which department sets that or is
legislature
it's in statute but how do i know that
mine that my homestead's valued at 140
000.
your assessed value so we're looking at
assessed property value right right
mr chair um
early early on in this bill that
representative ames is speaking with i
worked talked with um at that time jeff
mcclinch
over at
the school funding fairness project
and also in municipal and county
government we had had a bill
that ended up getting stuck on the table
because of covet that addressed the fact
that
originally
when the low income
tax statewide property tax abatement was
set put in place there were a large
number of people who were able to take
advantage of it but over the course of
time because property values had
increased but the level was so low
but in the program the number of people
who were eligible to climb because of
the value of their property declined and
it was it was
we had actually recommended passing a
bill that raised
that level um
because it was just out of whack it had
been in there for 10 years and it was
you know you weren't you were only
eligible if your house was worth 60 000
or something and that had been
you know very very few so um
that was a bill that we we did pass i
think this year that already did go
through so
it's set on assessed value and um
and this was a reasonable assessment
given
given the
increase in property values that we've
seen in the state in the last year or
two
that's where it came from
does that make sense am i well i i i
i understand the concept behind all this
uh i'd like to see
you know the
achievement levels of students that are
coming out of these homes or 150 000 or
less if there's any relationship
i don't think that was part of the
um
the
calculations representative ames can
correct me if i'm wrong we weren't we're
not looking at
um
the achievement of the students we were
looking at how
getting some property leaf property
relief for low-income families property
tax relief for low-income families
that was the goal of that bill
and that that's the goal of of raising
these caps
these these homers might homeowners
might not have any children you know
they might have got that
it's just to help because the property
tax is going up and up and up um
especially in low
property value towns the taxes going up
this was a way to help
stories that we hear always of the
the elderly people living on a fixed
income or the low-income families that
are struggling to pay their taxes and
are attacked property taxed out of their
homes because they can't afford it
anymore that was what the goal of this
was to help those people get some
property tax relief
i you know and and in addition i think
it's also an important distinction
because representative porter mentioned
programs that invo that evolve
abatements this is not an abatement
program uh in fact the the school
district and the municipality still
collect all of the property taxes that
they would collect even without this
program this is a refund that
that goes directly to the homeowners
from the state
so it does not take money out of the out
of the either the local property tax
revenue collected and doesn't place any
additional burden on
on on other
property taxpayers that that do not um
and i i use the wrong term i'm sorry
representative i did misspeak with that
statement refund
yeah just add i think that the um
in in developing 1680 there was a
recognition that
the burden the tax burden in some
communities was much too high
and
that needed to be
be
fixed
but it all there was also recognition
that the tax burden for some homeowners
even with very low rates in those
communities
was still too high and
that for those homeowners there needed
to be relief so this is
responding to the reality that after
this is
done if 1680 is done there will still be
significant dependence on the property
tax wherever you live whether it's
bedford or portsmouth or
uh claremont and uh
and
that's where you live and if your
circumstances
are not up to the level that enables you
to stay in your home by paying whatever
the property tax may be then this bill
is intended to provide help to you
in those situations so it's a part and
parcel of a larger picture
and inevitable we think
uh continuing dependence on the property
tax but even more even
in a more even way
and providing relief to individual
taxpayers who
even once all of that happens still need
help
let's keep moving here unless can i just
um
in deference to representative ames's
work um
i would be remiss if i did not mention
the fact that there are in fact folks in
bedford who have been there for
generations
they're farmers whose land
far exceeds property values that have
typically allowed for any kind of
abatement
however
their income
has them cash strapped and sometimes
losing their homes because they can't
afford to pay
the taxes
uh and so i'm hopeful that
we keep that in mind when we're when
we're tossing around uh
names of communities because right
within my very own community i have
uh as one would call them the haves and
the have-nots so
i'd like to pick up on that actually uh
and point out that in this bill there's
another section that sets up a study
committee
on the property tax relief program
to
look at
other categories that may not be reached
renters
what about renters you know
this provides no help to renters this is
a homeowner tax relief program
and what about farmers maybe there is a
special aspect to
farming and farms that
that can be targeted in a
through a statewide relief program and
that's not sort of dependent on opting
in at the municipal level that's
appropriately addressed statewide so
that's why that study committee is in
there
recognizing that
this
this is targeting homeowners
but we know that renters
are affected by property tax it's
indirect but we know that's true let's
look at that and see if there's some way
we can deal with that too
yeah i i i i concur with you represent
mullen what you just said
all across northern new england you had
people turn their property into tree
farms
especially in maine along the coast
where they couldn't afford to stay on
the coast yet their incomes didn't match
current use which we have here in the
state uh for those properties which are
larger than that 10 acre
that was my concern to begin with the
its
income as well is is the driving force
you go up to lincoln
and franconia area
and properties are valued very high
but incomes are not
at the same level as the valuation the
property
yeah yeah
and
we've put a lot of emphasis in recently
in reducing the uh
business tax rates
in in the states so that there's some
relief for businesses paying their taxes
but we've done
this is an attempt i think to give some
property tax relief to people who who
need it um as well so
just
so just throw that in for a little can
we move beyond now this area right
we've gone through that um
let's go and get beyond the statewide
education property tax i'm sure that
there's going to be a lot of concern
from some communities on that
uh
we don't have to rehash that right here
now no i i don't think so and i think
we've gone through most of the bill now
um and um and and we do have um mark
from uh from the department
maybe it's good to good to pivot over to
yes
after that we can start looking at
impact yep
oh and i and i think it's also worth
just highlighting and and um
representative ames talked about it how
um how ways and means has retained
essentially this tax portion of the of
the bill and the property tax relief
portion of the bill
um for not retained it's been it's been
uh
interim studied so so they have that and
and in committee and we'll be uh interim
studying that so um so i think that's
that's certainly something that i think
helps
our committee
as well thank you
great thank you
thank you
we should have these spreadsheets on a
little wider paper
the font is like a point zero zero
i think i should just grab one dick oh
sorry
sorry i was wrestling without mark
manganello administrator of school
finance with the department of education
i apologize for the uh the font is
the font is i think 12 or 13 but um i
was wrestling with a printer and i in
the printer one so that
this is what we have
uh
so before what i handed out was a fiscal
year 24
adequacy spreadsheet um there's a lot
going on in this formula so it's
actually
the first page is working as looking at
just the weights and then the second
page starts dealing with the grant
amounts um there's usually it's now
getting harder and harder to put an
adequacy spreadsheet on
on one page so i thought i could split
it up and that might help with the small
font but
it's still pretty difficult to read so i
apologize for that
up at the top i just want to say that
this is a preliminary analysis
typically the process whenever the
department's looking at an adequacy
change
the department can certainly do an
analysis by itself but we prefer to have
the lba involved
it adds for a better quality control
process so this is my
this is my first crack at trying to see
the fiscal impact of 24. as uh
for hp 1680 as introduced
just like when policymakers are dealing
with adequacy formula changes it's trial
and error sometimes it's also trial and
error for the department as far as
making these calculations and being
introduced to a new formula
so that's what this this spreadsheet is
um
so i'll start i'll start by
with the first page it's the weights and
i think um uh mr artinger walked through
that uh last week
um these weights are
eventual essentially what you're doing
is you're calculating you're adding up
the weights and eventually you will
times the weights by 6 500.
so 180m so each school has one adm
or each school that educates is
responsible for educating a student has
an adm
that's going to count as one weight so
one student count essentially costs
counts towards uh
6 500 dollars in the in the
formula
then we move on to fnr fnr is 1.49 so i
think that turns out to be around 9 000
uh per fnr student because the weight is
1.449 for each fnr student
you know you know while we're looking at
base adm and fnr adm one of the
challenges we're currently dealing with
as we as education knows is the fnr
numbers are
uh
a challenge right now so that 34 000
number that's probably low um
there's probably more than 35 or 34 000
students out there
that are eligible for fnr but as you all
know about the usda wish issue and the
waivers
both house and senate are trying to
figure out how to deal with fnr data
currently we have a hold harmless for 22
23 we have a modification
to the fnr data using a governor
the governor's formula that he
introduced in hp2
that's based on ratios um but 20 fiscal
year 24 has no modification in law to
address fnr data so i just put in the
the
currently collected number which is
you know low it's not modified it's 34
000.
um so just give away roll on i think we
ought to be asked questions as you go
through sure so the ratio would be let's
say in
fy 19
to the regulation here's the percentage
which was fnr
and now taking that same type of ratio
and applying to whatever our enrollment
is right now that would be the number of
f and r we would have yep that's the
modification in 23 correct it's a ratio
base so you're looking at um actually
uh school year 1920 seeing what your f
and ratio relative how many f r students
do you have relative to the total
students um if it was 50
um
then you look at the current data where
you might have an enrollment drop but
you might have a really significant f r
drop and um we apply that 50 ratio so if
we're looking at current data and say
you have 100 kids we would apply that 50
ratio to bring your fnr numbers to 50.
um but the actual data might say the fnr
numbers are 10. so we're going to bring
you up to 50. so that modifies the fnr
data to match historical ratios of fnr
to total students
that's the 23
modification that's occurring does that
parallel the application to the federal
government for various grants what we're
doing
in terms of using a ratio to identify
our fnr has that been approved by the
feds um
i'm not aware of that um
the fnr of course it's um the feds um as
an idea the feds um i don't know where
they're at as far as
allowing flexibility in our fnr numbers
um
we could yeah it's possible but yeah um
i have no information on that as far as
if we're using that for our federal
grants i know carl perkins is based on
fnr too
yes a lot of grants use fnr data yes
yes right thanks thanks rick and thanks
mark for um for this and this side
discussion i think is really important
on the free and reduced price lunch data
it obviously affects much more than new
hampshire
and affects every other state and it
affects um federal uh programs uh as
well so um so
and and mark you've been involved in our
ad hoc
um
i mean house finance and education
um committee to to study this
have um have has the has the usdoe
provided any further guidance on on use
of um
free and reduced price launch data than
what we've talked about so far
so the only
most states
new hampshire is unique in a sense
new hampshire for federal funding new
hampshire allocates based on fnr data
we're kind of the exception not the rule
most states use census data but new
hampshire has because we have very small
school districts
we don't historically like the census
data has margin of error we haven't
relied on it it can produce really odd
results when you have
census data determining poverty
so we've always used fnr data but we're
kind of the exception so at usd um
usn might not have a global policy to
deal with it because new hampshire is a
little unique
um what we have
uh talking with uh our
food and nutrition program
there is a possibility for us to use
medicaid data as a direct cert
so currently we use snap tanf
foster data to certify who is fnr data
so we don't need an application for that
we can just go to dhs's database and get
information about the income of that
family
so we're currently exploring the
possibility of having using medicaid
data to direct cert our fnr data and so
that might put less pressure on
communities to get those applications if
we have a bigger pool of data to direct
cert from but
it's a little it's a pilot program so
you usa doesn't just allow anyone and it
involves the center for medicaid
services allowing that data their data
um to be used for that so um it's going
to be a process where we've started
looking into it
and seeing what we need to do to far as
far as to get into that system and be
allowed to use medicaid to direct cert
um
but at the moment that's um we're just
exploring that thank you very much yeah
we won't pursue that we know that karen
nunberger's committee is looking at that
right now and there are some states that
have been approved to use that
information but uh we're going to have
to hold on that
yeah
so
that's the fnr data and
a lot going on with student data of
course
this is this this this bill is looking
10 years in to the future
it's a 10-year phase-in
and you know student data
obviously pandemic impacted as well
hard to know how to predict that as well
fnr data has had some variability
because of the pandemic as well
but just moving on
sped data there uh 29 762 times the 4.29
weight
that gets you the the sped weight
english language learner
4 600 students there times it by the
2.20 weight
you get that weight
the
kind of tricky one and this took a lot
of uh
a lot of playing around with and trying
to get this right is this new metric
these those metrics are we're pretty
used to dealing with but this new metric
is based on
over here the big column that says
weights it's based on the number of adm
in your school district uh you follow a
very specific formula to get a very
specific weight
and so reading this bill
i um
i
assumed
i know it says adma but we're making the
assumption admr
universally at the moment
um because we paid adequacy of admr and
eventually this committee hopefully
we'll see senate bill 386 which is going
to fix that it's in the senate currently
so
i'm looking at the adm of the school
district not the adm of the town to
calculate this weight so for example
acworth is part of fall mountain acworth
only has 79 admrs in the town but the
school district of fall mountain has
north of
1200 students
so i'm looking at the school district
that athwork is a part of
and i'm looking at do what bucket do
they fall into they fall in the one to
200 they fall into 201 to 600 do they
fall etc do they fall in the bucket as
described in law
um
i'm first determining what bucket they
fall in
and then i'm adding in that negative uh
it's a very small small small fraction
i'm even smaller with a print on the
page uh very very small fraction so for
fall mountain it's it's um negative zero
zero zero four nine times 80 m and for
this calculation i'm timing it by the
adm of the school district
um so i'm timing not by 79 but by
something north of 1200 which is fall
mountain
and then we're adding at the very end
we're adding and basically when you
times a negative number times a positive
number like the adm of a school district
you're producing a negative number but
then we add uh at the very end we add
something to it so we're adding 1.008
under the law
for that particular school district and
it brings the number positive and so
then you take that positive number and
then you would times it by the admr of
the municipality to get the weight for
that municipality so it's it's a little
technical there's a lot going on there
but that's a new calculation and i
believe i did my math right
one of the other kind of uh
challenges with this is some towns are
part of multiple school districts so
when i was trying to calculate that
essentially i looked at
and i'm going to mix amherst is not a
good example but i'm going to go down to
ashland
ashland is part of two school districts
their high schoolers are part of the
pemi baker district and then below that
they're part of the ashland school
district so i apportioned out the
weights based on how many students
attend uh within the town of ashland are
the responsibility of the particular
district so
some of their students fall in that
under 200 bucket and some of those
students fall in this 201 to 600 bucket
and basically i apportioned out the
weight based on the percentage of
students that fall within each
uh
that attend each district
so it's a little complicated um but
that's that's the methodology i use for
this um i believe it's it's how we would
do if this bill were to pass
i believe that's how the department
would approach it but um
might need to study it further to make
sure it's accurate and it does what it
needs to do um so that's kind of a
technical aspect um any questions about
that
i know it's kind of a new concept
th this whole concept in this
uh
uh handing out somebody based on the
population
is
are
some some
dis states break it even further
by
elementary middle
high school population
and some break it up by geographic
location
um i understand where we're going uh
it's
it is
somewhat
complicated
uh for these districts which have
districts co-ops and districts within
we may have to revisit it a little bit
but
so so rick and mark
excellent work on this
um i think what um you know when mark's
talking about the the complexity it's
not so much with um
with with you know free and reduced
price lunch or special education or ell
those are you know
um
we call them weights but essentially
that's the same as as the differentiated
cost factors that we have in the current
um you know in the current formula where
special education has a differentiated
cost factor of 0.5
pretty close to 0.5 you know multiplied
against the base cost of an adequate
education
where it gets where it gets tricky in
here is in the school size so this is
this is determining
a um
it's a formula
driven by student characteristics and
district characteristics so fall
mountain a great a great example so you
might have a small municipality sending
to fall mountain but it's the district
characteristics as you've applied uh
here
and
and uh those those district
characteristics as they relate to total
district enrollment or or adm
have a
have yes a complicated formula because
we didn't want to have enrollment cliffs
where if you took on one more student
then you would lose
a tremendous amount of money so or or in
to tremendous amount of grant
potentially so
um so
this this formula takes on you know the
formula of you know y equals mx plus b
where you've got the the slope and the
y-intercept and that's the negative part
which always becomes positive when you
add the the intercept
into it and gives you a smooth
transition as the size of your school
grows
and um and and you and you you know can
continue to
increase efficiencies with uh with
larger in larger districts
um so so you know we think it it really
does does approximate
what uh what uh what our total statewide
budget uh comes to in fact in the in the
final column here mark you uh you get
pretty much right on
what the um what the total um state
spend
combination of local revenues and state
revenues spent on um on you know uh
publix by public school districts across
the state in the uh the year where where
this calculation was was based which i
think was
was uh fy 19 so
yeah and i'm sorry f1
yeah fy 19. yeah
and
just to talk about it this is a new
concept that i just went through pretty
quickly
i'll say that um
i had multiple columns this is a roll-up
obviously i had multiple columns of work
of dividing out the districts dividing
out the buckets so i could present it
that way which would
it just would be a
lot more columns on the spreadsheet um
but yeah it is a new it is a new concept
and there's a lot of uh a lot of excel
columns that went into it and this is
just a roll up of where it ended up um
but yeah it's and thanks for that uh the
sort of explaining of the algebra with
that that's that's helpful to understand
it's fun
so uh and then uh to
moving forward that's the weights for
the school district size
as as uh we don't have uh this formula
doesn't uh
doesn't specifically call out geography
but you maybe you could
school district sizes sometimes a proxy
for geography not exactly um
well in other states geography is very
very important
i was in one state where hydrofoil
served as a school bus
and you had to have a pilot's license
run the hydrofoil but i i think in terms
of looking at weights in schools it
costs more
i feel and some people debate me to
educate a high school student than it
does a
elementary student due to the technology
required in that high school
for those
credits to graduate
and we that's how we came about with the
universal class initially in the old
formula
but
there
i i can explain how a pinkerton works
where all these sending districts are
going to pinkerton
and
maybe that's
maybe that's a discussion for another
day
because
that's an ongoing discussion which we
have um
don't go there right now please just
keep marching along with your formula
yep uh
so uh
the grades are the next part of the
equation as representative vlad chairman
lad was pointing out grades is also part
of the formula here um grades six to
eight uh 38k in the states add that 1.42
weights
yeah one or multiply by that 1.428 you
get a weight there
nine through 12 12th grades um 59 51k in
the state multiply by 0.42 weight you
add that to weight total and then we're
going to get to the end we're going to
sum up all the weights we just produced
we went through
the methodology here to get all these
weights we have 450 000
units of weights if you want i guess you
want to call them that
now we're going to times that by that
and that gets us that 2.9 billion dollar
number which represents luna was talking
about uh we typically spend um north of
3 billion a year when you look at all of
our k-12 district
funding expenditures um it's uh so it
gets close to that that three billion
dollar number
and so this is the weights i'm going to
move on to the next
one last question mark so if i change
the weight in special ed from a 4.29
to a 3.29
i'm going to have to increase somewhere
else i'll wait somewhere else to come up
with the amount of money we need at the
end
if that's what your objective was
if you're if you're looking to hit that
target that three billion dollar target
then then yeah you would have to play
around with it as far as take from here
add to here
um yes
so i i'd like to ask representative ames
and represent luna is that 303 billion
target what we're aiming for based upon
what we're seeing out of the doe 25. so
so
um
short short answer is yes and um and
what that what that 3 billion you know
2.957 or whatever it it it comes to
um
and so this is the total spend less
federal less federal dollars um
that that total statewide um
school district budget gives you yields
a total statewide student outcome
so so that statewide budget
approximately three billion dollars gets
you a statewide outcome which the
average is is
is
strong nationally it's strong regionally
and uh and it means you know the average
student's 50th percentile is the is the
average
and so what um
what uh what what this what this bill
does
is is carves up that that three billion
dollars into district budgets what would
it take the the hillsborough deering
school district to educate its average
student to a statewide outcome what
about manchester what about hopkinton
what about bedford what about haverhill
what about wolfeboro and and um and and
it does that for every every district in
the state
and um and it used
the um the
well it did that and then it determined
weights
that would allow you through a more
straightforward algebraic you know
formula that we could put in statute to
to essentially come to the same numbers
as what the statistical analysis did
so
if you if you then
change the special education weight
bring it bring it from
let's say 4.29 to 3.29
and increase the
the free and reduced lunch weight from
1.49
to
to i'm making it up you know 3.75
yeah you might get to the same
three billion dollar number but now
you're no longer approximating the um
the
budgets that would be required for
hillsborough deering to get to a
statewide outcome and for manchester and
bedford and haverhill and every other
district to get to a
statewide outcome you're now departing
from that that from that
evidence-based uh model
um you know based on what districts are
spending and what outcomes they're
getting
so you can do it you can get to the same
total spend but you know your but you've
you've now left
uh you've now departed from the idea
that that we really want to close
opportunity gaps between
hillsborough deering manchester bedford
wolfeboro and all the other districts in
the state
see you know the one area that when we
had the commission that i was concerned
about
is that we have a targeted amount of
money to get the kids to the performance
level that we want
in order to achieve that we have these
weights strung across all these levels
but i i believe that even in the special
ed domain here
that
the
to fund
a child that's getting very little iep
support but has an iep
another a 26 000
amount
is high
um and i don't want to see districts
starting to say i know how to get more
money in my budget i'm just going to
give more ieps out and believe me i've
seen this happen in schools
and sometimes kids are identified too
early they're over identified etc
and that's not good for the child
either
so
so if the average cost is twenty six
thousand dollars for all our
are our children that have ieps which
you know roughly i'm taking the four
point
two and multiplying by the yeah getting
roughly 26 grand
in my head so
if
that's the amount of money we need to
run our programs then
we're we're
targeting money towards a
outcome that's a performance outcome not
necessarily targeting towards the
providing the service for that child
i don't know if i'm really communicating
clearly what i'm trying to address here
but many states have
weighted amounts based upon iep
and based upon the cost to deliver that
particular iep we know we have some kids
are very very expensive children in
terms of their iep and others
years ago we just had in monitoring and
they didn't get any service now they
have some support and maybe 15 minutes a
week
does that cost 26 000
i see there's room for abuse on this
this weight weighted formula so so a
couple things on that rick and and i
think your points well taken um on it
that
but but also there's a there's a
self-correcting element to to um to this
bill as well where where the formula is
redeveloped every
analyzed no no less frequently than
every 10 years and i would advocate
every five years based on on current
spending and what the um what what the
outcomes um uh
these districts are
are are delivering for their for their
students so so
you know
perhaps what what what could be done to
also help address this
sort of in a in a nip it in the bud um
standpoint is to include that in the
accountability uh standpoint you know
provisions to uh to help prevent or
any any sort of um you know inflation
of either of of any of these student
characteristics whether it's
free and reduced price lunch special
education ell
to um
to prevent any abuse on um uh you know
on on that but
but you know fact of the matter is the
same is true today
where um where we have the
differentiated aid factors and you could
clearly i suppose a district could
inflate the number of of you know
english language learners or or students
in special education to um
you know to to get additional money and
there's currently no feedback mechanism
in the um in the system but there is a
significant difference between seventeen
hundred dollars and twenty six thousand
dollars
um
certainly a significant difference but
but again what this is what this is
about doing is is identifying the
budgets for every district that that are
required for um for state outcomes
statewide outcomes and um and districts
are still responsible to um to to get as
far into that um that that meeting that
cost
uh through the um through the local
minimum contribution and and where the
state comes in is is if that's not
sufficient to get there so that
hillsborough deering wouldn't need to
work any harder than newport wouldn't
need to work any harder than hopkinton
wouldn't need to work any harder than
wolfeboro in order to um to to get to
their uh their foundation opportunity
budget and the the state grant comes in
to um to make up the difference see i
i'd only propose that
as we did here in that center column
dealing with the weights for your the
number of students you have within your
district there's various categories
there
to then have a similar breakdown
in special ed
where you could do it by weights of need
uh that for that child
doing your formula here your whole
concept it could be done
it's just a lot more work to do that and
it's going to
i'd like to see some other you know
options
discussed at least
in in this area
as you've brought up rick and i and i
think it's it's it's something that the
commission uh also recommended and and
unfortunately was not able to um
to review is is those different
categories that that may have different
cost factors to them and i think that's
that's we had that discussion yes that's
very relevant to to do i know that's
something that the research team was
very interested in getting but we i
think we only had the data for one year
for whatever reason and
so so as that data becomes available i
think that's something to look at
something also i think important to
point out in um in the um
it's in the it's in the bill and and
certainly in um it's in the bill through
the way the the
the foundation opportunity budgets were
calculated that it does not include
categorical grants like special
education aid um
you know as being one of those so so for
for
uh students who fall into for special
education students that that fall into
some of those
categories that you were talking about
that's outside of
this budget because it's contained
within categorical
representative porter
thank you um
i may be jumping ahead of you mark but i
wanted to just
ask you i'm looking across the um rows
here i'm looking at antrim one of my
towns
and the final figure
in the far right
is six million four hundred ninety
thousand five hundred dollars
is that the figure according to all
these numbers that it costs
would be
yeah you're no i'm sorry
my little my little uh
eyes are
okay but the same figures okay that's
what you according to all these figures
that's how much
it would cost to educate
the kids
to provide adequate education for the
kids in antrim given all these weights
and numbers
so i i as far as the policy aspect i
would refer to members on the commission
um it's the it's it's antrim's part of
uh reaching that um
statewide average outcome is that
correct
and then from that
we figure out how much the state's going
to contribute and the town's going to
contribute
right so that okay so that's what that
figure is yeah so the so so the way that
would work and let's just
because i was just looking down the
thing and there's some huge numbers in
there like concord's got 68 million
um
you know there's a lot of different
differences and i know that's because of
the number of students but
i just wanted to know what that figure
was and i think you answered yeah so i
think mark's probably going to walk us
that's on the second um
part of the handout
we'll walk us through how you get to
that okay i have one last comment on
this front page
i'm looking at the
weight for fnr and we know that poverty
is a significant factor
that
contributes to
our metrics which get back an
achievement
and then i look at the the sped column
and we have 34 000 youngsters in one and
29 or close to
30 in another
and yet the weights are so different
would we get more mileage if we were to
take some of that weight and move one
other way if in fact
we were to get into a breakdown on the
different weights for
for
special ed ieps different ieps and put
the difference over into a weighted
increase for fnr
we we posed your question to the sped
bureau um the one you had last week
chairman ladd um as far as the doe 25
the cost of it cost of special education
i actually ran i ran the math real quick
about uh 780 million and sped cost uh
k-12 district education 780 million
divided by 30 000 is approximately that
26 000 average that's the only
information i have available to me uh
yeah as far as the co sped students and
cost of sped students uh
but yeah as far as getting granular i i
don't have that information yeah and and
using averages like that is not always
the best way to
there's certainly some outliers yeah
yeah i'd like to see that plotted out on
a graph
okay let's let's move on to the second
sheet then okay
so
the second sheet is um
where uh we that 2.9 billion number um
rolled that over into the second sheet
so that's how we ended calculating all
those weights we got to that 2.9 billion
dollar number
um so that's the first that's column c
then um
in column d is the adjusted annual
foundation opportunity budget so
this is going to be adjusted over i
think in the bill is introduced adjusted
over i think eight years
or you know several years and so the
adjustment first off um no matter what
the adjustment will always be 95 95
off that 2.9 billion dollar uh so 5 off
that 2.9 billion dollar number that's
the first adjustment that is made to
calculate the annual foundation or just
an annual foundation opportunity budget
but then there's another adjustment and
this judge judgment is going to
progressively get
higher so the amount decreased will be
progressively lower uh over time
in that first year in 24 under the bills
introduced it's 70 percent and then i
think the next year it's going to be 74
so over time over the the phase-in
period the adjusted annual foundation
opportunity budget is going to grow each
year
uh or
that percentage
cut from it is going to decrease each
year so eventually holding all these
weights constant eventually it would be
95 percent of that 2.9 billion right now
applying that 95
adjustment plus the 70 adjustment it's
equal to 1.9 billion
so that's how that and basically
the way to think about this as far as
comparing it to this is kind of the cost
of an adequate education so this is the
benchmark that the state is determining
it is it's uh uh uh schools must achieve
this is sort of the benchmark uh similar
the way adequacy is cost of inadequate
education is so that number is going to
progressively get big holding student
weights constant which i know is not um
the case um holding student weights cost
it as we uh increase the
percentage applied until we get to 100
of the adjusted annual foundation
opportunity budget that's going to get
closer to that 2.9 billion number
then the next step so that sets the
standard the next step is looking at the
local side
so the next step is a five dollar per
thousand with the equalized valuation
property statewide um
five dollar per thousand tax rate
applied to each of these towns um and so
i i did it just consistently applied the
five dollar per thousand uh there's some
possibility to um under the bill i think
there's some possibility to go under
five five dollars and then there's a
potential financial penalty but um we
can get we get out of those weeds later
or we can get into those weeds later um
so column e there's five dollars per
thousand
um
so if we do five thousand dollars per
thousand and we look at every single one
of these community that's going to raise
1.1 billion dollars uh statewide
so we have our standard which is 1.9
billion and then we're going to look at
the the five dollar tax rate which is
the locals can bring in 1.1 to achieve
that standard that's their sort of their
contribution
um but we're not done there yet the con
the minimum actual minimum local
contribution is to look at
what is the adjusted annual foundation
opportunity budget and what does the
five dollars per thousand and pick the
lesser of the two so that's going to be
the actual minimum local contribution
that a community must hit
or expected to hit
so the standard is 1.9 billion the
minimum local contribution of the local
taxpayers is expected to be around a
billion
we uh do that standard that 1.9 billion
minus the one uh 1 billion and we get
how much the state com
contribution is the state opportunity
grant and that's about it's 935 million
but it's
you know essentially 2 billion minus a
billion equals a billion
that's the state opportunity grant
then
there's a
there's a there's a transition grant and
this might be new and i'm good this get
really technical and i i cuz i only
found out about this a few years ago but
the bill says and and the rep the
authors of the bill might want to
revisit this because it might not have
been uh what they intended
but when we say total education grant in
rsa 198 we do not actually mean all
money that gets distributed under rsa
198 colon 42. the total education grant
as defined in as implied in statute does
not actually include stabilization and
it would not include that swept hold
harmless so this is probably not the
intent uh uh if the representative
speaks that this is probably not the
intent of this this uh
calculation but i included that number
here so that might be something if that
was not the intent it might need to be
revisited um uh by the sponsors of the
bill
um
so normally our 23 adequacy is expected
to be i think uh
954 billion uh when you include
stabilization the swept hold harmless
but right now i am only showing
780 million so that's just
a technical thing with the adequacy law
so um
using that definition of total education
grant i'm going to look at
is your total education grant for your
particular municipality is it higher
under the 23 formula
is it is it higher under that than what
you would be getting as a state
opportunity grant if it is
um
uh if it is then you're paid the delta
the variance you're essentially hold
harmless in this transition grant
and for 24 under the bill is introduced
the transition grant is going to be 100
and the bill
progressively has that grant decline
over i believe an eight year period
over several years that that transition
grant will eventually climb and decline
until it's non-existent so it's a
phase-out so there's two things going on
here if we go back to the beginning the
annual foundation opportunity budget is
phasing in so that's ramping up
this the obligation the state uh the
state and local uh institutions must
contribute to funding their schools
that's going to ramp up over time and
the transition grant is going to what
holds you harmless is if this formula
negative
negatively impacts you that is going to
progressively transition down over time
so that's kind of the phasing up and the
phasing out
so
the your state funding is going to be
that opportunity grant plus a transition
grant if you're eligible for a
transition grant so the number there is
a billion dollars and 48 million
um
then the sort of unique thing with this
program this this bill
is
now swept is uh 100 not 100 it's 97
deposited in the education trust fund
and a municipality uh uh gets to keep
three thousand sorry three percent
of the swept warrant um
uh for themselves
so it's actually swept is not an
education grant anymore under this bill
it's a municipal grant
but since we're comparing apples to
apples here swept is currently an
education grant so i'm adding the 3
retained swept as basically state aid
just to make it apples to apples here
even though this swept to the three
percent swept or retained will be going
to the municipality and not the school
district
so
everyone's getting a three uh everyone
that pays everyone every community pays
swept every community is getting a three
percent retained uh three percent of it
retained the rest is going to the
education trust fund
uh
so that is how swept is factored and
factored in with this bill
and then if we go to the very end here
we have hb 1680
total state funding total state funding
is going to include that opportunity
grant that transition grant and you're
swept retained
um
and it equals 1 billion 59 million and
then if i look at current law adequacy
uh current law adequacy is estimated to
be 100 951 million
so
overall we have a net change of 107
million
but if you look at the town by town
some communities are receiving
less
less and i think a lot of the reason why
they're sweet receiving less is because
of the way the transition grant is
structured
i've not played with these numbers too
much but um
uh
you're losing if you're losing a swept
hold harmless grant or you're losing a
stabilization grant factored in as your
23 hold harmless that's gonna
put a negative number in there
also another thing to consider uh for
the the sponsors to consider is
uh
the hold harmless truly isn't a hold
harmless uh
oh sorry it's not gonna show up as it is
a whole harmless but it's not going to
show up as a whole harmless on these
type of spreadsheets because 24 has the
cpi adjustment that 23 doesn't have so
that's also producing some negatives
here
so that's just things to think about as
far as when you look at a spreadsheet
what is it telling you um that's that's
currently as far as i've got as far as
playing with these numbers and looking
at what this build does uh
that's the that's uh some of my insights
but other than that
uh negatives in column p
so in
likely more in reality a lot of that i
mean right now you're using the same adm
as as fy23 is that right um
uh so uh correct
yeah so so so sorry no um no that's not
correct uh
mostly correct except for there's no fnr
modification uh but yes right right
so so the what what i would say in p
when we see negative numbers they're
they're really um what's the term um
artifacts coming from the fnr the the
in fy 24 we don't have an f and r
modification
um
they get it right yeah and and then the
cpi indexing um
well um it's mostly cpi so
uh the 23 there is an fnr modification
to help districts out uh 24. i am
comparing it to 24 current law i'm using
24 current law adm numbers and uh to for
to build the hb 1680 analysis um i'm
also using it to compare it against
current law so that's actually apples to
apples the cpi is not the apple store
it's when there's yeah so so so
essentially negatives in p are really
are really artifacts from from that as
opposed because the the hold harmless
really is there to bridge most of that
um
yeah the hold harmless truly is looking
at 23 and an attempt and functionally
holding you harmless although the
definition of total education grant is
different than say what you get under
our say distributed um
um but no uh the the hold harmless is
designed uh certainly does what it's
intended to do it's supposed to hold uh
uh it works as a whole armless it looks
back one year but just when you're doing
an analysis and you're comparing current
law versus
projected
proposed law
it creates those mark i'm looking at the
two largest school districts in the
state manchester and nashua
and i'm seeing manchester coming out
with an additional 12 million dollars
and i'm seeing nashville coming out with
an additional thirty thousand dollars
uh both have
double digit and a thousand students
and what would be the right reasoning
for one district
getting so much more
and the other not
i want to say
so
i don't know
that's
uh i'll have to look into that i have no
i don't have an answer off the top my
head i was going to say stabilization
but it's definitely not stabilization
[Music]
i don't i don't know i have to look into
that that's a really good observation as
far as the difference there thank you
representative porter
thank you um so i want to get back to
the five dollar um
tax rate
where are we looking at that
i'm look
yeah column e okay so
i'm unders if i'm understanding this
right and i could be very wrong
we're using a
an assessed value in the town
of five five dollars per thousand
assessed value
is that a universal assessed value
around the state or just in my
particular town so
a
four-bedroom 2500 square foot house
in
nashua would have the same assessed
value as a 4 bedroom 25 square foot
house in hillsborough or bedford or
the amherst no it's based on the the
property values in your town what i was
nodding my head was because it's
equalized so your your community might
have its own assessment schedule
each community does their own assessment
some of them are really
uh more frequent some are really
assessing every year some are assessing
on a delay so it's equalized to match
what is the market um
it's the it's the market value
assessed
in my own town so if my house my 2500
square foot house in hillsboro has an
assessed hillsborough value of
two hundred thousand dollars i'm going
to pay five
dollars times 200
for my tax but that's same size house in
bedford which might have a 500 000
assessed value would be paying five
dollars times five hundred
years that's correct okay thank you
this whole business of valuation of
property
i'd like to talk to my insurance company
and find out what the replacement value
on my home is it's going to cost the
same amount to replace it in the south
as the north the value of material and
all has gone up
it's out of whack
and and just talking long term so this
this bill has a a 10-year
long-term phase in
the department has been
kind of we've been comfortable
projecting adm out
to some extent because we're used to adm
we know that data we can see it's pretty
consistent um the pandemic has certainly
made projecting adm more of a challenge
because
we're kind of a wait and see we don't
know a lot of kids
left their district public school um
immediately following the pandemic we
don't know if they're going to come back
right now it doesn't seem like it maybe
they'll come back later
so adm's harder to predict and then i
think another thing as far as projecting
this out for the full complete phase in
and phase out components of it um
that five dollars per thousand is
property values increase so we have the
foundation opportunity budget and then
we have that five dollar minimum
um if adms are decreasing that's going
to go down
and if property values are increasing so
it's going to
you know before you make an adjustment
um say every five to ten years you make
an adjustment but that's that's what i
would predict is the trend line but i
definitely don't have any methodology to
tell you about the the future of the
real estate market i just know that it's
very very hot right now so i would
expect equalization equalized valuations
to rise
are we using
there was a lot of discussion i know adm
a verse adm are
um
this seems to be based premised upon adm
a
uh so i did the whole the whole
calculation is based on admr okay
um adma is where student attends the
school amr is the resident district um
so this is all r this is all r thank you
and there was um
i don't know if this is getting a little
this is getting kind of technical uh
representative luna and representative
cordelli were going uh having a
conversation about how to talk about
those weights for the school district
um so i think representative luna
expressed uh
he would like the school district to be
based
on the adma of the student
where the student attends the adma of
that district um
i can totally see the logic in that but
i think it's going to be
difficult you have to be workarounds so
we'd have to
every student
every student essentially belongs to us
every student attends a school district
essentially belongs to a school district
and they have a name that school
district has an adma but for students
that we send out of state we would not
have the adma of that particular
district
and for students that go to non-public
schools we can't really calculate the
adma of that so it's just all admr to be
universal and i think it probably
achieves the intent um but that's just
from a data perspective we have to use
admr
um rick yeah mark also brings up a
really
important other point that is not in the
bill
um but um but uh representative ames and
i have discussed it is dick still here
yeah yes right there um
um and and dick i think you brought it
to um to really our our
discussion but as valuations rise
uh in the five dollar
local contribution may need to be
adjusted uh downward um um
uh
given given the fact that the the east
the the um you know the 100 of the
predicted cost
is really stable for
you know for let's say a decade of time
so so that's something that i think um
you've you've mentioned that we do need
to consider that in in in legislation is
that right
yeah and mark that's what you were
talking about right yeah just projecting
this um you would expect ev to change
rise we expect it to rise currently
unless there's a real estate market
crash
so yeah that's going to certainly impact
state aid under this program
further just represent porter you have
your hand up yeah sort of because
it works i just go for it yeah okay so
five dollars per thousand of local
valuation plus
swept
okay so
that but the swept money is not being
counted as local contribution now that's
being counted as
state contribution
uh
yeah the swept is um
the swept is just now under this bill
swept is just a
tax source to the etf um you don't uh
you were
municipality gets to retain three
percent of it but basically it's just
dollars for the etf so when a
constituent looks at their tax bill
they're going to see school tax five
dollars per thousand swept tax
whatever the rate is for that year for
swept tax um yeah the the local school
tax might be more than five dollars
depending on if they want to um uh
uh
raise additional funds above the state
yeah yeah right but yes they'll that
when a taxpayer is looking at their tax
bill under this proposal hb 1680 um
yeah they'll know that their swept is
going to the education trust fund uh
that their community is keeping three
percent that it's not one hundred
percent uh
yeah okay thank you
are there further questions right from
the committee today
represent
thank you mr chair thank you mark for
taking my question
so
on the transition grants
yep am i correct that i could estimate
how much less
a community is going to get in a
transition grant from year to year by
looking at the just at the percentages
based upon the original transition grant
i see representative ames is nodding his
head behind you so a little more than
that because
the foundation opportunity budget goes
up
every year too
okay so you have you have both these
things sort of converging at the same
time as the foundation opportunity
budget goes up in the state grant to get
you there goes up the transition grants
are going down
so i
if the transition grant goes down by 10
percent
but the foundation opportunity grant is
going up would the difference actually
be less than 10
on that figure are you are you looking
at uh i'm sorry you're are you looking
at bedford
okay bedford caught my eye as well when
i was going through this and i have um i
did an analysis on 25 um it's not in
front of you but i did look at 25 for
bedford because i was curious i saw
bedford got that 76 000 uh decrease and
i i couldn't off the top of my head i
couldn't think of why that was and it's
because of the cpi adjustment um when
comparing 24 current law versus hb 1680
proposed law
um but i did look at bedford because i
thought what representative luna was
pointing out what happens to a community
like bedford right
there
when you
decrease when you increase the annual
foundation opportunity budget bedford
doesn't become a transition grand town
anymore they become a state opportunity
grand town okay so so yes so the math
could get it's going to move around a
little bit but as that foundation
opportunity budget increases there'll be
less transition towns
right in the long term
so
how can we predict
looking at the
one million four hundred and fourteen
thousand dollar transition grant
is that just gone in 2025
uh uh
uh
us
for 2025 for bedford yeah um
if we're no longer
that transition grant disappears because
you're getting a state opportunity grant
that's greater than your 23 numbers
you're 23 uh yeah and can did when you
did the numbers do you know what the
increase in that state opportunity grant
would be
uh it's on my computer but i can okay i
can email you it doesn't have to be now
i just want to know what the sticker
shock is going to be all right thank you
mark
so so what's going to be the the
the reaction we get from the loudons in
the world and the molten burrows the
world and the wolf pearls of the world
when they see
their line
you know it's over a million dollars in
those communities
um
so so you know and i think this is that
that's a really good um question rick
and and i think there's a couple of
things that
that that really dr factor into that
conversation
certainly the uh the the discussion
last week with respect to
towns that raise more through the
statewide education property tax than
the cost of an education and whether
that's actually constitutional
and um and and that's uh that's
certainly that's one of the main
uh considerations behind ways and means
uh continuing to take a look at um at
that policy
the um
you know the other um the other piece is
is i would say um
the uh you know continued series of
litigation that we've had here in the
state with respect to school funding and
whether or not uh ultimately in the
conval case it's going to be found
whether
new hampshire is is providing a
constitutionally adequate
uh funding plan um
for school districts or if they're or if
they're not
and
and and then i think there's the
sort of like the i don't want to call it
an anecdotal piece but certainly places
that have high property tax values uh
feel that that somehow they're not being
treated fairly in in our school funding
uh design
and and
you know mark's done a tremendous job on
this and and uh and i can't wait to be
able to sort of sit down with with dick
and uh and and and go through go through
this and and bring some questions back
uh next week on um
uh on this but uh but also the number of
students that live in um in districts
where uh where they're now seeing their
budgets
um
designed so that they can close the
opportunity gap so that the students in
those districts the average student in
those districts has a real good shot at
a state average outcome as opposed to
what their what they what what they're
getting right now
and um
and when you take a look at the number
of students that that are positively
affected by a plan um like this it's uh
it's really overwhelming and uh and it's
strong at the start and i should say
it's overwhelming after a decade
and um and you know these are the things
that i think i i certainly am not nearly
as eloquent as representative milor is
when he talks about
closing these gaps and why we do this as
a student-centered
program as a student-centered policy
looking at you know what it's not it's
not just the kids in hopkinton i'm
concerned about but it's the kids in
claremonts the kids in newport i talk
about newport all the time because it's
25 minutes up the road
and um and they've got some of the
highest taxes in the state and and
and honestly
the lowest
outcomes in the state and you know i
hate to hang that on any school district
but certainly
those students
deserve better
yep we certainly have some issues out
there you have the conval going on but
you also had londonderry earlier which
said that
all students regardless of the community
live in whether it's a poverty community
or a wealthy community
are due an adequate education as we
define an adequate education
and so you're going to have you know
different sides of
the coin here coming in and and
questioning this
so we have our work cut out in front of
us here in terms of policy and and i and
i don't mean to say that that students
in new london certainly
certainly they deserve the opportunity
for an adequate education as do you know
students in wolfeboro and students in
newcastle and we had uh
bill ardensher come in and say ardently
that he sees that this would pass the
constitutional issues at least that's
what i interpreted from that and then
you're going to have the opposite saying
well wait a minute we have an attorney
saying the opposite so
regardless how we go it's going to be uh
contentious
representative porter
thank you mr chair and can i ch change
the topic just a little bit and talk
about charter schools
because i i'm very i tried to read the
bill on the charter school area and i'm
i'm confused
so can you just give me a very brief
you know five sentence
how are they funded and and how do they
work into this and how do their how do
their um
outcomes get measured if they're not
required to do what public schools are
required to do other public schools i
can give you five sentences on all of
that so so currently charter schools the
the department of education does collect
performance
data on charter schools uh for many
charter schools that have
disaggregated subgroups that are that
are less than 11 in in
in student count
that data is not reported uh publicly
but for those some of the larger charter
schools you'll see that the the the data
is publicly available regardless the
department has the data and they can
calculate um you know
you know
performance budgets and things like that
um currently charter schools are funded
um using the per-pupil formula that's in
the um
the statute right now they don't receive
stabilization they do receive
differentiated aid
factors and they receive another
i don't know remember thirty five thirty
six hundred thirty three hundred dollar
kicker
per student
yeah yeah but it's it's it's the it's
the per pupil funding calculated in
9840a
plus an additional 30 300 3400 3500
for non-vlax yep yeah yeah for non-villa
and then velox has a different different
different funding formula
what um
what what house bill 1680 does is
develop a funding mechanism for school
districts
it's all it's it's it's a funding
mechanism for school districts and how
much does it how much does it cost
a school district to educate all of its
students to a constitutionally
defined adequate um
adequate education that's defined based
on outcomes
and um and so so what uh what are in the
uh the sections of the bill
uh with respect to charters and they
would obviously equally apply to any
other per-pupil um um programs like efas
um
that um that that
it needs to be studied that the
commissioner needs to take a look at
what's the what's the way to fund
charters what's the way to fund efas
what's the way to calculate those uh
variables and that's what you bring to
the um you know to the to the budget
discussion
and um
uh or or codify in statute either way
but um but but what we what we do know
is that is that is that the basis in
house bill 1680 is uh is is how to fund
school districts
okay we gotta get we're close to
wrapping up for today but
what we have is one more subcommittee
meeting here this is an early bill
so this committee has to make a
recommendation to the full committee
on where we're going on this we've had
now an opportunity to go through the
bill and look at those policy
considerations
and now we've heard uh gotten the
spreadsheets on
you know how to fund this program and
where revenues may be coming from or how
they're you know broken out over all
these towns
so we've we've got some basic
information here
and
many just questions been asked
i would ask that we all be thinking of
further questions to discuss at the next
meeting here
and then close that meeting we're gonna
have to make a recommendation either otp
itl
interim study
otpa i there's a lot to this and quite
frankly i see a lot of study
to square this away
in
taking it down maybe some of the other
alternatives we've just discussed today
that i don't think we're going to have
all those answers so i don't want to you
know be saying this is how we have to go
but um
be be looking at this in between this
week here and come up if you have any
questions i know everybody will run back
and look at the line for their community
look at as a whole for the student in
the state statewide that's what it's all
about so
any other discussion from the committee
at this time
thank you thank you mark thank you rick
and members of the campaign dick i
wanted to apologize for my questioning
about the um
assessment portion i had not read
thoroughly that section that
representative mullen pointed out to me
so i apologize if i came off
thank you
okay it's a good section i liked it when
i read it thank you there there's better
a lot of information here for us to be
looking over so thank you very much mark
for coming today and and doing that for
us and you too dick
appreciate it
and we'll
adjourn this meeting and we'll come back
next monday
10 a.m same time same place
you
b
i think we might as well get started
here but five after people may still be
parking and all that but uh
we'll get started
uh as i was talking just on the side uh
there's a lot going on right now in the
university system and they're in
transition but in my discussion with you
uh
even though they're actively engaged in
negotiations and all that uh i gather
it's therapy your opinion here that uh
that need not interfere with our having
this discussion that we're having
concerning
uh how best to a the
community college system in uh
delivering its programs and attracting
students and retaining them
excuse me
and so i think we'll continue today
with just your input back
um
with possibly the idea that it won't be
necessary to have another meeting
if we just set up a process by which
we're able to continue
uh
communicating with each other about
what's in progress and and how we may
assist you in improving access in the
community college system
is there anything in the committee at
this point that anyone wanted to bring
forward or
yeah i apologize i couldn't stay at the
last meeting right through to
uh three o'clock or 3 30. i don't know
when you left
what i did is i left early
and i went up and had a meeting with
president don burks at psu
a real good meeting we discussed a
number of topics but we also discussed
the issue
of the relationship he has with kids
that are coming down from white mountain
to plymouth state
and that maybe perhaps have the
associates degree and how
president burks is addressing that in
terms of when they get engaged and
matriculated towards a four-year degree
and i shared with him
the legislation that i had obtained i
did a search with the education
commission in the states and looked at
all states in the country in terms of
do they accept an associate's degree
from their community college system and
at the university level
in terms of uh
of going on and getting that four-year
degree so that the student that's
applying doesn't have to go and jump a
lot of hoops and then a lot more
expenses to take certain courses which
not have been uh
aligned with the
the where the uh they need for the
four-year
and i showed him the
sample legislation we had from tennessee
and he had already been familiar with
some of the things going on there seeing
that
tennessee's i guess made quite a few
gains in terms of relationship between
the community college system and the
four-year schools
and that's in fact when we looked at
legislation earlier for concurrent dual
enrollment the the manner which we
adopted ours was exactly what wyoming
was doing they have seven community
colleges there that go on to a similar
type university system so
um
we looked at tennessee and i gave him
the sample legislation he said this
looks good this is what we are wanting
to do and in fact are doing at uh
plymouth state
so what i've done is i've gone ahead and
worked with legislative services last
week
and had an amendment put together
which
everywhere tennessee was new hampshire
is and it basically says an associate
science or associate of arts degree
graduate from any institution
in community college system of new
hampshire shall be deemed to have met
all general education and university
parallel core requirements for transfer
to any institution in the university
system of new hampshire as a junior
and then part two not withstanding
paragraph one and this is where
president burks and i had some
discussion uh admission into a
particular program school or college
within a university in the community
community system in new hampshire
shall remain competitive in accordance
with general applicable policies
so that you're wanting to come in with
your general ed background from the
associates or you want to get into
engineering obviously
you may have to look at the policies
that that program is run by and you may
not have what's necessary but you could
come in as a general liberal arts type
you know student
so i put this forward for a discussion
today because it may it's associated
with
the the idea of the community college
being offering four-year degrees but
this is just backing it off a step or
two and the four-year degree would be
offered by the
four-year accredited school but the
associate's degree would lead towards
that uh first portion of that four-year
degree
so i put this together so we could have
that discussion today
seems logical to me
but uh there again too it hasn't it's
only been passed by
one one college our one university
president at this time so
mr chair i just offer that out for
discussion and probably work with today
a little bit
it may help us get to the end zone we
want to get to
a lot of the other issues that are going
on
can be dealt with through the higher
education study committee which is a
statutory committee between the senate
and the house and it's met once this
year i'm sure we're going to have to
meet many more times this year
but
i also would suggest that
the
there are a lot of ways that issues like
this can be resolved
at the local level by that i mean at the
community college level and at the
university level without statutory
uh
rationale or
legislation i put this forward though
with the idea that
this is going to put the message out to
elsewhere in our state that kids are
finishing the community college system
hey i'd be interested in knowing if they
should come out of a massachusetts
school with an associate's degree
whether they would come in the same way
it's a possible way to attract students
from out of state and we're competing
after that same demographic maybe this
way to really attract them to our own
state thank you
we are streaming too
the world's going to hear you mrs
preventure
thank you mr chairman and now members of
the committee for the record my name is
catherine provencher i serve as the
chief administrative officer of the
university system
um
i so thank you very much representative
vlad for for the amendment um
this is the first time i've we've had an
opportunity to look at it so
my initial reaction is i need to do a
little bit more research
the
the other thing i would just point out
that um
i would say this isn't just relative to
community college system and the
community college system degrees
and representative ford i believe you
mentioned that it's important to make
sure that we aid the community college
system students and of course it is but
it's about access
to public higher education in the
granite state in its entirety
rather than just the community college
system
again the first another
initial thing that jumps out to me is
the effective date within 60 days of
passage
i don't know how long it would take to
facilitate all this work when i look at
the the tennessee statute and forgive me
i don't know enough about the structure
of tennessee's statute but when i look
at the language
it looks like
the the piece that an associate of
science or associate of arts
degree from a tennessee community
college is deemed to have met all the
general education
and university parallel core
requirements
is under a subsection
where
um
all state institutions of higher
education have collaborated and
developed a transfer pathway for at
least 50 undergraduate majors so
again
i have not researched this but from the
plain language it looks like a pathway
for 50 majors was
already set up
and then those associate of science and
associate of arts
transferred over and i'm sure the
chancellor president lloyd can
answer questions about
some of the curriculum and all of the
associate of science and associate of
arts degrees at the community college i
just don't know enough about the core
curriculum for all of their associate's
degrees
and do they all transfer into the
general education requirements at the
four-year schools
does that make sense
the this right here
yeah there were a whole slug of them out
in front there
good afternoon
mark rubenstein on behalf of the
community college system
we actually see this as as
a helpful and constructive step
our our commitment to our students
focuses on the programs that we offer
we serve to educate
and the expectation whether it's a
physics course or
is that we're there to teach
and we believe we teach that
with quality the same concepts that that
would be found in any other institute
post-secondary institution
so for us in a lot of ways not only is
this
uh
clear about the efficiency for students
and contributing to affordability
through
pathways that don't require repeating
courses but it reinforces that
commitment to quality that the
consistency that you would expect
whether you're learning in berlin
whether you're learning in littleton
whether you're learning in durham
is what we would expect too
so we we see this as a constructive step
uh as you note in the second paragraph
represent vlad the
amendment would still require admission
to a program the still expectations are
established by the university system for
receiving students into those programs
but students otherwise eligible to be in
those programs wouldn't necessarily need
to repeat coursework that in fact is is
demonstrated as consistent within the
community college system
i don't know enough about the
the curriculum and the associates
and actually um chancellor you might
know because you can sit on both sides
of the table here so
all of the the all of the curriculum can
you put the mic in a little closer all
of the curriculum
for all of the associate's degrees
issued by the community college
in your opinion would meet all of the
gen ed requirements
at our four-year institutions
for programs that are designed for
transfer yes
i'm gonna go back and forth here for
just a minute but that that's a key
point for programs that are designed for
transfer
which gets me back to the first section
of this
tennessee statute that talks about a
transfer pathway
where the amendment doesn't talk about
i don't see in the amendment
well first of all i i put this out just
to really steer some conversation and
the direction and really to respond to
what i had heard
from
some others that
there's a lot of money and time put into
these associate degrees
and
and coming from a
a perspective that when i'm looking at
our high school curriculum we're now
looking at it not by course but we're
looking at by competencies
do those competencies that are required
for a student even at the
collegiate level or the post-secondary
level
are the competencies there
through that associate degree be it for
a associate's degree in the science or
associate of arts
do they parallel with the competencies
are necessary for a person to enter in
the junior year of of
of a
four-year degree
i know that
when i was in the service there were a
number of courses or
areas where i received competency from
the university of maryland
for my participation in various programs
within the us army
without having to do it through the
specific another college or some other
place i got they granted me credit for
that i sort of like i think what
uh
uh dr rubinstein's done with the some of
the programs while he was at granite
state
um i i feel that there's there's really
a need
to
support those students that come in with
the associate's degree so they don't
have to start taking courses all over
again if we're not aligned down below we
need to be aligned
we need to move towards stackable
credits
that you get at one level that stacks up
and leads towards that other end which i
think that that's something that the
the four-year system is
has definitely thought of and hopefully
working towards at different levels i
don't think it's a statutory
responsibility
that can be done through your your
boards that you have the administrative
board and all that between the
presidents and and working with staff
um
it's just that we're running out a lot
of time we need to get on this and move
quickly here there's a lot going on at
the higher education levels in terms of
restructuring and organizing and and
trying to capture the students from all
over new england and beyond to come to
our schools here and i think this is one
way of doing it so yes uh we do have
copies of the tennessee bill i think you
had it i gave you a copy
and i if it's transfer i'd like to see
us work something here where we can come
out with language which is supportive of
this particular
goal and and get something moving along
here
so that
an outcome can be
told to our public that yeah you got
that associate's degree you can go earn
a four-year degree
go for it and you won't have to spend
more money in replicating what you were
told
you know that was
working towards a college degree and do
it again
to me there's i think we can go beyond
that and i do concur with
president marx at psu i think it's a
good idea
i think that
what if you know where they're coming
from with what they have then we should
be and it's within our state community
college system and our state university
system we gotta tie these two
organizations together so that we're not
losing time and money on the part of a
student
just to step in and clarify one issue
though that i did hear from a little bit
of
no one is saying that you
should be exempted from taking
prerequisites for a required course
there's not any idea of that at all the
gen ed thing is just
just the idea that basically if you pass
gen ed requirements in any institution
in new hampshire it should satisfy that
requirement in all other institutions
that
will never protect you from the faculty
members they didn't teach english
history the way i teach it look we live
with these creatures
we know them and we just say no no no
thank you charlie and sit down you know
but yes
that will always be the case we had
someone in a
high school who was saying that their
chemistry course couldn't be replicated
anywhere else you had to take it right
there you couldn't get a high school
diploma from them
we all deal with these kinds of things
in academe
that's not what we're talking about
we're just talking about if you're
requiring some kind of social
studies or other things that this course
at this university should be equivalent
to the one over there that is the
principle
that's being required not the
course specific kind of representative
ford i'd like to add one last thing on
line 12 of this proposed legislation
and i'm open to a you know modifying in
any way it says university parallel core
requirements for transfer
so we're talking about transfer there
and meeting requirements to get into
that particular program you might be
wanting to get into it's contingent upon
those aligning and meeting the
requirements of the program you're
transferring into if they don't then you
have the option at the university level
say no it's not going to work
we're simply requiring you to take in a
different math course that's more
advanced than the one you took for the
gen ed requirement that's
fairly customary if i understand
in my experience at any rate
oliver can i ask a question please jump
in uh i'm going back to our meeting last
week last week
i seem to recall i need some help with
this
that there was there were either
discussions or an agreement between
white mountain community college and
plymouth to take
i'm
i'm not sure i want to use the word
program but take chunks of
of of sort of
yeah programs that students had
completed and those were part of the
sort of the agreement if that's the case
then
we've got the beginnings of a pathway
between white mountain and plymouth at
least
it seems to be that would be moving in
the direction where we would want to be
moving
i need clarification i guess
to be sure i'm interpreting that
correctly
sure can i just respond to that mr chair
please so and i want to be clear it's
not necessarily just white mountains
with plymouth state the community
college system has what's called a block
chance uh block transfer or the chunk i
like just as well uh the block transfer
and that is for general education but
also it's expanded to uh certain
programs uh business as a program human
services education we've gotten to the
point where a lot of those really align
very well and do transfer in
i will also just highlight of that's
plymouth state you know we have that as
a community college system we have a
block transfer there i'll work backwards
i was a keen state graduate my undergrad
and you know at that point we were
working you know course by course so at
the time i went back to nhti and i said
which courses actually go to keene state
as a transfer so we're still doing some
of those one-offs with some of the other
institutions i would say plymouth is a
little further beyond
not mentioning granite state by any
means but keene state and in the
university system
university of new hampshire and durham
don't necessarily have the block
transfer with as many as plymouth state
does
we talked about last
week though
there are a number of there are
agreements and a number of programs from
all of the community college system
schools
to
i know the university
that all those gen ed courses will be
accepted and transferred in it's just my
again i apologize
this is my first time seeing the
language and the amendment it reads that
an associates associate of science or
associate of arts degree graduate from
any institution in ccsnh
shall be deemed to have met all general
education and university parallel course
requirements for transfer
to any institution as a junior
and i just
maybe president lloyd do all associate
of arts and associate of science degrees
at the community college system
meet those
curriculum such a you know that you
mentioned business and social science
and all of that i just don't know
i think i'd be remiss if i i didn't say
there you know some of it depends i mean
there is not an exact uh transfer to
every single school that you know every
credit is taken in you know and i'll use
the applicability term once again as
well if not always applicable the
general education tends to go intro to
sociology intro to psych uh you know
some of those the quantitative reasoning
math you know some of those the more
basic level tend to go english go but
when it gets to the specific program
plymouth state may say intro to business
comes in absolutely and here's all of
these but it may not because there's a
separate paul college of business out at
unh for example
liberal arts will go because it's a
college of liberal arts you know all of
our liberal arts will go on there but
the engineering school may not so there
is not a blanket but i do want to take a
half a step back and also say at the
community college level our associate
degrees are all designed to be
transferable that is the intent in our
advisory boards our advisory committees
spend a lot of time making sure that
they are transferable i will also say
the receiving institutions uh all have
different programs and courses so even
though it may be transferable to one
institution it's not necessarily
transferable to a multitude of
institutions
just a follow-up question to what you
just said
um
is it not possible sometimes at least it
wasn't my experience so i'm asking if it
isn't yours
to transfer in credits that may not
fulfill this particular requirement or
accept it as free electives
so they transfer all the credits they
don't lose any college credits they just
may have some more requirements they
have to meet in their new program sure
that's very true i think that happens
probably more often than not yeah
if if i might replicate it before ju
just to add
within an institution
a student at a university who starts as
a liberal arts student finishes the
first two years as a junior still would
not have satisfied the requirements for
junior standing in the engineering
program at that same institution so some
of this is really the alignment between
the two-year program and the four-year
that the student is pursuing so i don't
think this was intended to overcome and
the second clause of the proposed
amendment that talks about the
prerequisites and the admission i think
still speaks to the need for a student
to have a plan in the first two years
that maps to the third and fourth year
for the four-year degree
oh i i quite agree in my own experience
anyone else care to pick up on that
mr uh chair
if if i if i may i have to uh follow up
on dr lloyd's uh comment about
personally and should i in my view
have some discretion as to what they
accept
to personalize this a little bit i
transferred from the university of new
hampshire to plymouth state many many
many many years ago
and at that time um plymouth did not
recognize plus degrees in other words i
had some pl b plus or c plus two anyway
the um plymouth would not take the the
plus so my b plus turned into a b for
example at plymouth now that that's
probably probably been changed but
that's a policy of the accepting
institution that i think needs some
respect so i have a couple questions one
of which is
english composition is a fairly
universal
requirement wherever
so if
in many cases the receiving institution
insists on
a c or better so my first question is if
a student at a community college get a d
in say english composition
by the the proposed language that miss
prevention just
focused on which i am too
it looks to me like that dee would have
to be accepted by the receiving
institution
is that
am i reading that correctly and is that
appropriate uh anybody
except i would just have a follow-up
question and ask if it is coming as
intended to come over as a sole course
or a whole degree because if it comes as
part of a whole degree that had been
granted and is buried in there and comes
as blocks transferred the credits come
but not necessarily the grade
so i guess it would depend if you want
to just bring the course over a basket
of courses versus the entire degree
so the d
would
so accepting the course that had a
degrade in it would depend upon if it
was coming as a folder it's part of the
package
so the the credits would come
but not
the great like if i get a d in english
comp and east everything else in my
program got the associate degree my gpa
was 2.8 and i wanted to go to plymouth
state as a block transfer they would
take the degree not necessarily any of
the gpa the grades they would take the
credits to walk in okay so even with a d
they would take the credit it sounds
like
okay and my second question um
again going back to lines 20 to 23
um
a program like radiography which i
mentioned last week or dental hygiene at
nhci which i have a little more familiar
familiarity with
um
would
again typically the receiving
institution will look at the proposed
courses coming in and say okay the
designation of this course and the
course description doesn't match
perfectly with ours but it's close
enough we can call it whatever
but something like uh dental hygiene
where there's no
uh
comparative course to my knowledge in
the university system
um
the language here looks like it would
mandate that the dental hygiene courses
be accepted and and i'm a little
concerned about that is that how you i
think ms prevents your kind of drilled
down on that piece of it so i'm kind of
sharing her concern and my question
is what would happen to dental hygiene
courses
or radiography
well if i might and again goes back to
the question of the alignment of the
first two years in the last two years
none of the university system programs
are lead to a bachelor's degree in
dental hygiene
but a lot of programs
require about a third 120 credits about
a third of those credits are general
education about if they're those credits
are the major and if they're those
credits are elected i'd say you've had
you'd have a transfer student who had an
awful lot of elective credits in dental
hygiene
and have relatively little flexibility
to complete the bachelor's degree with
the last 60 credits of the program but
again it would be the degree and junior
standing the credits transferring but
largely as elective
i see so the so the credits the dental
hygiene credits would not proof be
raised to go away they just could not be
applied to the uh to a
formal degree in the university system
if there's no comparable department
within the university system to apply
those credits toward a particular major
then then yes i think they would simply
be transferable as elective credits now
again this this is a lot easier for me
to say sitting on the community college
side of the table than the university
system side of the table
but i'm i'm simply thinking through a
typical
degree in a liberal arts program whether
it's english or history or philosophy
where a significant component of the
degree program is in fact elective and
although a student may choose to use
that to explore other areas maybe
develop a second major or a minor in
this case the student would be bringing
an awful lot of dental hygiene courses
that that probably would
fill the elective bucket
okay so they'd be considered as
electives and they would count but not
towards the degree but as electives as
you said they'd have okay a lot of
elective credits thank you very much
please
thank you
so i'm not that familiar with the
university system um but
i live up near colby sawyer college and
um was an adjunct there
and i know that
the nursing program which was one of
their big programs
you know
they had to qualify
from
i believe it was their sophomore year
to actually get accepted into that
program and the qualifications were
you know largely due to not only the
courses they took but also their grade
level
and i'm assuming that university system
probably works on the same premise on
a certain high
you know pre-med maybe and nursing and
maybe some of the other
advanced that you know pre-law the ones
that are going to go on to an advanced
degree in some way or expect it to could
you talk about that please
uh yes representative uh thank you for
the question and that i i'm guessing
that was what paragraph
two in lines 14 to 16 on representative
vlad's amendment are
trying to address
the the nursing programs are extremely
competitive
um to be accepted into even from people
within
as you mentioned
could be a freshman or a sophomore at
unh and you might not get into the the
nursing program engineering is another
highly competitive program
at unh
um
so i i believe
representative ladd that was the reason
for paragraph two in your amendment
well that comes straight out of the
tennessee law as well so i would i would
assume then
that yes there you
the program remains comparative and in
accordance with the policies of the
institution you're in program you're
transferring into
so
as a as a four-year school you can say
you don't
match up what's needed for this
but you can come in as a junior
and and
and and try to get in that program after
you've messed around with us a little
bit if they even get accepted in that
program you've got to be uh
qualified to get into approach i think
that's what this is saying
i i would say it's saying right there in
line 15 and 16 or down below on the
lower side on 25 to 26.
may i just have a follow-up that that
one of the things i think that
is bothering me about this is the
accepted as a junior
that's that's
what i'm having issue with i i have no
problem with them
accepting credits and coming in as a
package and that sort of thing but it
seems to have that written in granite
for no
other analogy that um it would be
difficult for first you know people in
in nursing and and some of these
veterinary science some of the highly
competitive
areas
representative if i may say
because the community college system
offers nursing programs at all of our
campuses
a student who's completed the degree
from us the first two years
is a nurse
academically qualified registered nurse
academically qualified university system
has
rn to bsn programs notably at gsc i
think unh may be offering one now as
well that allows students to come in for
that junior and senior year with junior
standing in fact in granite state
program come in
after the third year with senior
standing
so so the model is there maybe that was
a bad
uh analogy because like i said i know
that kobe sawyer nursing is a very
hard program to get into
as they come in
and
but i i i think it would be
difficult to immediately say that they
would have junior status i mean i i
think some of them
might come in you know with
credits that would only take them to
maybe a sophomore and a half or whatever
i don't know how much of a big deal that
is at the university level the status of
what year you're in
it's usually based on the number of
credits i think that you've accumulated
and if i may follow representative
in the arcane world of registrars
normally and it varies a little bit 56
58 or 60 credits brings you junior
standing and to complete one of our
associate degrees you are bringing 60
credits or more so so on purely just the
credit count level student would have
junior standing if the programs line up
it would be perhaps junior standing in
the program they're pursuing if a
student was a liberal arts in the first
two years associate of arts degree
but wants to be in engineering may still
need additional prerequisites in math or
or physics or or chemistry before
eligibility so again there may be some
some instances where
as president lloyd said it depends
but but the junior standing would almost
be the easiest part that they'd have
junior standing even if they still had
additional prerequisites
to be in junior level classes for a
different program than they had started
in thank you that makes it clear
and to be clear and i hope i hope we um
effectively communicated that this last
week
the university system is committed to
ensuring there's affordable
quality access
to higher education
from the community college system
i'm i'm not going to say though today
that the university system is going to
support this language as is i just don't
know enough and i'm not i need to go
back and talk to
others at the institutions again because
we're just seeing this i don't know that
we're going to come out and say
yes absolutely every associate's
degree of science and arts at the
community college system is going to
transfer everyone in as a junior
maybe but i i need to do a little more
homework on it before i can oppose or
or support the language
anyone else uh care to respond to that
mr one more time sure i i want to just
say that i think representative tanner
is on to something and i i share her
concern uh strictly with the word junior
because junior
if that's in statute that implies that
someone who's a junior has two years to
go
so if someone
does not have the right credits to to
match up to a program in the university
system um
i think the transfer thing is fine but
to to strict to come right out in
statute and say they'll be considered a
junior that
concerns me as well
i believe
representative tanner had a question
first no okay excuse me
thank you very much mr chair thanks all
very much um
so
yeah i think you know along along this
is i mean i
mean shannon will remember this too
going back
what was it 20 years or something like
that when we were essentially doing the
same thing
uh with the engineering technology
programs at nhti and uh wanting students
to be able to seamlessly
enter their junior year at
unh
and um and it was a it was a tremendous
amount of work
in a program that where both the
community college had the program and
the university system had the had the
program
and in fact the program worked really
well on a two plus two basis where you
did your first two years at nhti and did
the remaining two years
at uh at unh but it still wasn't
perfectly seamless
at um at that point i think it it did
sort of come down to
to
you know concerns over you know
credits that would transfer and things i
know we've come a long way in in the
last 20 years uh for sure but uh
but uh but i think those those concerns
are valid um and there must be other
challenges too i mean you know what
about uh you know somebody that may be
you know maybe they were and i i don't
know where nhgi is in the in the
community college um interscholastic um
uh or intercollegiate um you know
athletics but for students that may want
to continue with with sports
uh at one of our university uh colleges
you know maybe they want to come in as a
sophomore and be able to be you know
three years eligible
um and i don't know would this affect um
eligibility or any other sort of um
you know
tangential
and i don't say tangential i mean
whether it's financial aid or or you
know other
things that are that um
you know are sort of part and parcel to
being a student at the in the university
system
if i may
and i don't propose to speak i presume
to speak for anybody other than the
community college system but i'm i'm
reading from the unh catalog
and it reads baccalaureate and
associated arts undergraduates are
assigned class standing on the basis of
semester credits of academic work
completed with a passing grade as
follows to be a sophomore 26 credits to
be a junior 58 credits to be a senior 90
credits
so the concept of junior standing is
sort of a normal thing independent of
how well you did if you got d's in all
of the courses that you took
so that your gpa was not a 2-0 you were
not going to be online to graduate but
you'd accumulated 60 credits
by the definition in the catalog you're
still you still have junior standing it
also has relevance as representative
luna was touching on for satisfactory
academic progress for federal financial
aid so the concept of being a junior
based on the credit work completed is
pretty broadly established in both
institutional administration but also
federal financial aid administration i
don't think it necessarily assures a
student that they've only got two years
to the finish line and ask the parent of
any student who's been a super senior in
college they will understand that
concept that that the finish line can
move if the student's academic work in
required courses doesn't bring them to
the to the finish line by merit
i confess i immediately began thinking
oh my god we're going to have to deal
with red shirting in this issue too
i was taken back a little bit but then i
recovered as the chancellor spoke
anyone
it's my finger
okay
glenn's only half trained me i'm part of
a human service
experiment you realize and i'm only part
of the way through my training training
so
um
i'll get there
but at any rate uh when we were chatting
before about where to go
after today and what maybe should be
done and what i would suggest and then
that's inviting everybody to say yay or
nay
uh is at this point we
asked the chancellor to
get the institutions and also the
university is appropriate and see if we
can arrive at those kinds of definitions
that we've just been spelling out here
about number of hours and put that down
and avoid terms like junior status even
though it may have one meaning to one
person it may have another to someone
else and just use the numbers
and that way we're not dancing around
that but the concept is
that if you've gotten all your credits
up to a certain level then you become
whatever that university says you are
i will caution you that this has can go
the other way too
i transferred from geology which
required five credits of integral and
differential math and finite mathematics
to english which only required three
but i got all five credits toward my
diploma
just the last two were free electives
on that so it it happens
moving around in any
set of programs
the one concept that i would say that we
have to honor without fail
is the requirement for prerequisites you
cannot put a professor in the position
of trying to seat someone who is not
prepared for the course
and i think we all understand that but
it may
be required or need to be put inside the
agreement because the professor expects
certain or
requirements to have been met prior to
enrollment if the receiving university
says that course doesn't require it then
you may have to take an additional
course that's just what happens when you
transfer among
programs but we'll have to spell it out
in this because it will be that kind of
a binding agreement
anyone else with concerns issues further
subjects
not seeing any um yes
i stand correct sorry
i would hope we still
if this were to pass like this
we still really need to guide our
students to the transfer pathways
so they don't
think they're going to get to one of our
four-year
schools as a junior
and then find out
they have to take a whole different set
of courses and extend their degree out
another two years
as opposed to where i started with
getting students into transfer pathways
where they know and there are lots of
pathways you take these courses here
and they're all going to transfer into
your major
two years from now
i agree very much that we need to do it
and i think that's
probably going to occur naturally as the
pathway
development idea continues i mean it'll
start to spell out but i think a clear
explanation of what's a required course
what will be an elective course what you
may have done here in your major may
only be an elective toward another
degree i was required to take an extra
year of french
you know and i wasn't thinking of it but
there it was so i took it
several years ago when i had the
occasion to work with sarah jane steen
up at to a psu prior to don coming on
board
we had a discussion how many years does
it take somebody to get a four-year
degree
uh at the university system and when we
looked at throughout the country
the figures which were oftentimes used
were six years it would take about six
years for a person to get a degree
i don't know what it is for unh or keene
or plymouth now
however it varies tremendously depending
upon a lot of personal circumstances of
the student
availability of courses
finances
ability to pay all those things stack up
i just think it's would be very helpful
that students know that by going to a
two-year school i can go on there and
enter into a four-year school
as a junior
i i think that what we're trying to do
is
i don't know we silo a lot of our
education for one we do it at the
the k-12 levels as well
we we tend to have a lot of ownership on
it
and we tend to get away from what is it
that you need to know to be a good
graduate of a four-year school or a
two-year school depending upon what your
degree is in
oftentimes when we miss out on those
competencies the ability to do it's
always what's on paper you took this
this and this
right now i can very barely tell you
what i took when i was in orono or when
i was going to get my master's or when i
went on to get the 30 hours on top of
that
but i can tell you what i've learned
through doing with my degree as a result
of my degree
so i'm uh
i would i would say i'd speak on behalf
of the student and the families are
trying to get kids through here and i
think this is also a good way of
retaining kids in our own state knowing
that
i can go where the school is close to me
right now one of seven community
colleges which are regionally local
schools we got to maintain
but the students have to know that this
state supports them and going to that
next step
and when we start saying you can't go
because you you're missing out on this
or that
i think we're missing the purpose what
education is all about
and so i'd encourage us to really think
about trying to figure out how we're
going to do this the next step is we've
got to get all these
these courses throughout all these
schools stackable
so that we know how they relate to each
other and so they can transfer between
keene and plymouth state or plymouth
state and unh just on that level alone
and and so we have a long way to go here
and i see this as a step to start
pushing us in that direction
and i'm pleased to see
that this is a consideration that's
being done on the on the
college community college level and at
the university level we've done the two
plus two we've done the three plus one
we've done all this stuff it's time now
to take the next step
thank you mr chair would anyone else
care to address that particular
conversation
well invitation yes uh i guess
it puts us in the position now of having
to go to those of you who are
representing the university and the
community colleges
to
take this back to campus perhaps mullet
for a while
maybe we won't we meet next week but we
meet the week after that is two weeks
enough time for you to have some
conversation this committee's only set
up for one more meeting oh really can it
be two weeks from now
well we're going to be getting into time
and we're starting to
close in on the governor's presentation
which i believe will probably be on the
16th
and session which we may be following
that they're not in granite they haven't
been put in place yet but we're coming
up on a lot
going on there
and this bill is going to have to be out
of here by
the middle week in march
so there's not a whole lot of time here
with everything else we have going on
we got 102 bills
can i just jump in and i'll defer some
of the wordsmithing in conversations you
know to to the collective group but i
just want to go back to something uh
representative luno said and that he
said oh shane you know 20 years ago we
were working on this i think we shall
just take a pause and say we've been
working on this for 20 years i mean i've
been in the community college system for
19 now and we're having some of the same
discussion so i'm just i'm excited about
this i personally went through this as
mentioned you know with my my keen state
and nhti relationship and anything i can
do to to help whether it's wordsmithing
i don't know about the junior status
piece we may have to talk about that but
uh you know i think i'm excited and on
behalf of the students representative as
you mentioned through the student lens
of from 20 years ago to where we are now
i'm excited to see this conversation
come back around and really you know
move the state forward so i just wanted
to go on record and say that
i'll only add the
work ahead
i think that chief administrative
officer preventure probably has the
heavier lift on the university side
because they're the receiving
institutions
but i i want to clarify that we have a
lot of pathways already in place we've
built a lot of articulation agreements
they align with specific first two years
mapping to the last two years so a lot
of that's been done
i don't know whether or not the language
has proposed would open that up to
anything more than that second clause
says which is that you still need to
satisfy the admission requirements you
still need to have the applicability so
i'm not as concerned about whether this
can be done
efficiently or appropriately but i would
defer to
cao proventure for the university system
side of this because they would they
would have to address the the receiving
end
and as i mentioned i don't i don't have
an answer to that today so if you need
an answer in a week then
i'll be back in a week
thank you
all right i presume
given the constraints we're under
we would
be obliged to ask you to come back in a
week and at least with the parameters of
what you could uh
commit to
uh you know and without trying to put
you in a box in any way uh just to do
that we would anticipate coming back and
hearing
what's possible and what's planned and
if in fact it is useful for us
to take any step at this point or have
we done at least the shove and we can
ask you to come back in
sometime in the near future and tell us
what the pathways are are looking like
i suppose the best way to anyone else
with
questions input
whatever
i mean obviously everybody in this room
has had some experience with this
it comes out in our stories and we all
have a legitimate
personal interest
as well and we know what a difference it
can make
my goal in calling for this was to
initiate this discussion and to open it
up so we could move forward and not stay
stuck
20 years ago or wherever it was
and i'm pleased to
to see the response and to note the
concerns because i think now we can
begin to address them and put them
behind us
so
see you in a week
thank you very much everyone
you